-Our first guest tonight is
the talented actress you know
from classic movies
such as "The Breakfast Club"
and "Pretty in Pink" and
more recently from "The Bear,"
"Dahmer," and "Riverdale."
She currently is starring in
"Feud: Capote Vs. The Swans,"
which airs Wednesdays
at 10:00 p.m. on FX
and streams the next day
on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-Hi, honey.
Oh, hi.
I come bearing gifts.
-Ooh. Gracias.
Thank you, thank you.
-Happy Thanksgiving.
-Mwah! Mwah!
Why is your friend
sitting in the car?
-John wants me to buy him
a house in Malibu.
Little Prince Pauper is pouting.
Once he realizes
there's a Manhattan
waiting for him,
he'll come in.
When's dinner?
-In an hour.
But there's lots of snacky,
drinky things.
I hope you like
nachos and tamales.
-I love!
[ Chuckles ]
-Do you know what that is?
-Please welcome to the show
Molly Ringwald, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
Please join us.
Take a seat.
-I'm kind of afraid to sit down.
'Cause I never wear skirts
that are this short.
-Yeah, we can stand.
Do you want to do
a standing interview?
-No, no, I can do it.
-That's great.
-Alright.
-Okay. Great.
Congratulations.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for wearing pink.
It's very fitting.
-Yes, I'm reclaiming the color.
-There you go.
Taking it back.
-Yes.
-I will say, you know,
oftentimes I will meet people
on the show who --
and I've known their work
over the years,
but I feel like
I really know you from
when I first saw your films.
And I'm sure you have
that all the time.
-Yes.
-And these are films now
that your kids --
you have a 20-year-old,
you have 14-year-old twins.
-Yes.
-They're sort of, I mean,
even a little bit older
than when I first
saw the movies.
-How old were you?
-I guess when they came out,
maybe I was about 13, as well.
So, yeah, 12, 13.
And how did they
respond to them?
-Well, I saw the first --
I saw "The Breakfast Club"
with my daughter,
my 20-year-old,
when she was 10,
which really is too young
to see those movies.
But all of her friends
had seen them.
And, I mean, because 10 years
old now is a little bit,
I don't know, like --
-Do you think it's older
or younger?
-I think it's older.
-Yeah.
-I think 10 now is
sort of more like 13.
-I think that's true.
-You know,
and it was a really
incredible experience.
I was really nervous.
I was really scared that
she wasn't going to like it.
-Yeah.
-Um, but she did.
She really liked it,
but a lot of the, you know,
the more racy stuff, kind of,
the more late-night stuff
kind of went over her head.
-That's a dream, though.
when you watch stuff with kids
and you realize
it's going over their head
and you don't have to have
a tricky conversation.
-Yes, yes.
-Yeah.
-And then I saw the movie,
actually, just recently,
a couple weeks ago,
with my 14-year-old twins.
Uh, and, you know,
I was again really nervous
that they weren't
going to like it.
And they both really liked it.
-That's great.
-You know, they did.
I mean, they didn't
pick up their phones once,
which I think is a triumph.
-Oh, my God.
-I mean, I was sitting there,
and, you know, I was watching.
The phones were there,
and I was like,
"How long is it going to take?"
You know, but, you know,
but they also took issue
with certain things,
which I've sort of
written about extensively.
-Well, right,
some things have --
It's an interesting situation.
Some things have aged
maybe not ideally,
but also I think
one of the wonderful
things about those films
is when you sort of --
if you can get past that,
it did talk about things
that kids still experience now,
even though it's, you know, in
some cases almost 40 years later
and not a lot of movies,
I think, address them
and sort of value
kids' intelligence
at the level those films did.
-Yeah, and they really
do still speak to kids,
you know, mostly because
really other than,
you know, the Internet,
which is huge,
it hasn't really
changed anything.
You know,
people are still bullied,
people still feel out of place
and different
and, you know, and other,
no matter who you are,
and sort of the amazing thing
about "The Breakfast Club,"
it was like
we all feel the same.
No matter who you are,
you have these feelings.
And that's a really
powerful message for kids.
-And I think it's nice to know
that you can watch them now.
And even if it does have --
or start conversations
with your kids
based on things that maybe
are harder to watch today,
that is what those movies
always were good at
is having conversations
that maybe parents and kids
didn't quite know
how to start with each other.
-Yes, exactly.
Yeah, I think it was maybe
one of the longest conversations
I've had with my 14-year-old
in a while.
-Wow.
So even after the film,
they didn't go straight
to their phones?
-No, no, we sat and debriefed
and talked about things.
-Did it get so awkward
at some point,
did you ever say,
like, "You should check.
You guys might have some texts.
You should -- You guys want
to take a phone break?
You know, see what
our friends are up to?
Let's get on Instagram.
Let's throw some likes
out there."
-No, no, no.
I was just, like, loving it.
I was just loving it.
-That's great.
This is --
I think one similarity
between this wonderful show
is this is a show
about another clique of people.
This is an adult clique.
This is about Truman Capote...
-Yes.
-...and this group of Swans,
as he called them,
which was, uh --
were a series of socialites
that were his close friends.
And over the course of the show,
we see that
not a lot of those friendships
maintained over his lifetime.
But you did play the one person
who stayed close to him.
-Yeah, I was not --
My character is Joanne Carson,
who for people who don't know
who Joanne Carson is or was,
she was the second wife
of Johnny Carson,
who was -- I don't know.
I mean, does everyone still know
who Johnny Carson was?
-Yeah, I think they do.
I think Johnny Carson -- Yeah.
Although I do feel like
we might worryingly
be at the end of that.
-Yeah. No.
I mean, my kids -- no idea
who Johnny Carson was,
but, you know,
so he was this huge, uh --
you know, pretty much
was the head of Hollywood.
I mean, not the head,
but, like,
hugely important in Hollywood.
And Joanne Carson
was his second wife.
And then they got divorced
and she was sort of
on the outs, you know.
To go from being with the most
important person in Hollywood
to all of a sudden not,
you know,
she wasn't invited
to the same parties,
she wasn't a part
of the same group.
And it happened
at around the same time
that Truman Capote had the
big falling-out with the Swans,
who were Babe Paley
and C.Z. Guest
and Slim Keith
and Lee Radziwill,
who was
Jackie Kennedy Onassis' sister.
Uh, yeah,
and Joanne was really --
They met in New York,
but they really became friends
after those events.
-This is a Ryan Murphy show,
and you play
a kind person in this.
And you were also in
"Dahmer," Ryan Murphy's show.
-Also a kind person, yeah.
-A kind person in that.
Um, I think it's--
I think no one
has ever had a two
Ryan Murphy show streak
of playing a nice person.
Do you have a dream if you
collaborated with him again
of what you would be cast as?
-Yes.
-What would you like to do?
-I would like
to play a psycho bitch.
-Okay.
-Am I allowed to say that
on this show?
-You should ask before
you say it, but yes.
[ Laughter ]
You are allowed -- Not only
are you allowed to say it,
you're allowed to play it.
And I feel like Mr. Murphy,
you know,
one of his many strengths,
he writes a great psycho bitch,
and I feel like --
-Yeah, I would be --
I would be thrilled
to play something
other than a nice person.
Although I'm really flattered
and I think it's really nice
that clearly he --
he thinks that
I'm a nice person.
-Right.
-Yeah.
But it would be fun
to play something,
you know, against type.
-Yes. It would be nice.
So you mentioned --
uh, obviously we mentioned,
I mentioned you're dressed
in pink,
and I, uh, grew my hair out
during the pandemic.
And I thought that my goal
was to look like
Steff from "Pretty in Pink."
-That's a good goal.
-Yeah. Now, I came close-ish.
I ran into a certain hurdle,
which is my current hair
does not have the fullness
of James Spader '80s hair.
-Neither does James Spader.
-Yes.
You know what?
I will say --
-Sorry, James.
-Yes.
It's true.
I'm closer to it now than he is,
so I've got that going for me,
but I feel like I did okay.
I mean, not bad.
-Oh, yeah.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad, right?
-You nailed it.
-I feel really good about it.
-You could have undone
one of those buttons there.
-Yeah, I also don't have
Spader chest,
but in general --
in general, it worked out.
Well, thank you so much.
I mean, coming from you,
that means most of all,
'cause, by the way,
I showed it to James,
and he was like, "Unh."
-Hilarious.
-Thanks so much for being here.
What a pleasure and an honor.
You guys,
this is Molly Ringwald.
"Feud: Capote Vs. The Swans"
airs Wednesdays
at 10:00 p.m. on FX
and streams the next day
on Hulu.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Kay Adams.